chaque gare cette nouvelle rubrique en
fait voyons saucisses et paraguay pour
l'invité de demander si son truc bas
marché si on va kiffer claude alexis est
avec nous quel bonheur nous voyons des
voyants voyeurs quelque chose il est
excellent claude rey sans rigoler et
quark essayera d'imiter claude larruy
mais c'est un hommage à benjamin
castaldi
il a une première question que je vous
pose est est-ce qu'il va encore se
marrer demain
est-ce qu'il va encore se marier c'est
le vent mais il ya quand même un enfant
qui se rend chez lui a toujours un
enfant ça va encore avoir un enfant
celui-là tu en as combien maintenant ben
j'en ai j'en ai trois et on ferait quant
à trois enfants intéressent ils ont déjà
un garçon 11 et 14 18 et 21
il a besoin de rythme est ce que vous me
voyez encore dans cette émission alors
on n'a pas besoin du voyant pour vous
répondre
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya plus
confiance en coin tu voudras que sinon
tu dis oui c'est que derrière ce site à
mon papa à aller nager par oui non
[Applaudissements]
la première n'a pas non mais alors que
vous allez continuer c'est vrai vous
allez continuer mais il notait bien
notre projet qui se met en place et
travailler en rapport avec une chaîne 2
de quoi les femmes un monsieur de femme
téva système alors ouais mais c'est pas
le même bon port avec les anneaux
project esthétique un moustique
ah bah mon avis elles vendent à
travailler dans une listed une bouteille
à travailler c'est pas tout alors
j'étais à trouver un tp mp racing chef
est ce que ce sera la dernière
non mais vous y serez pas sarkozy ne
pense qu'à la 4ème sacre était leur
gueule non mais est ce que je vais
trouver grand amour en dominant ce qui
va trouver le grand amour
voilà c'est bien la voilà la dernière et
c'est pas que ce sera la dernière
ça c'est plus sûr que quand à bourg
ouais on sert de votre vie sentimentale
oui mais elle n'en a avec l'asie dans
l'équipe à part toi avec la casi l'asie
à chaud c'était un voyage avec l'asie
l'asie base ils n'ont peut-être à mon
gars vous êtes d'origine asiatique
jean-luc au delà du tout combien de
temps va durer encore touche pas à mon
poste
et combien de fois d'ici là à gaza
annoncé son départ très bien
alors que l'accord va durer voiture
reste trois ans avec series à
l'animation
ah oui tpm potentialités avec moi
l'animal et deux oui ah ouais c'est
quelque chose je leur ai seulement deux
studios pardon ah ouais ça je le sens
c'est vrai ouais et un changement de
ligne il ya des personnes qui vont
disparaître autour de la table oui
est-ce que cyril sera un jour le patron
de canal+ voir allez savoir du groupe
canal+ à voir la chose que tu dis non a
dit la vérité parce qu'elle est et sur l
ens éditions arte la mourabaha cdi sur
canal voilà c'est dit sur canal on peut
aussi rêver se passe beaucoup de choses
sur l'année 2000 à fin 2010 8 mai après
la rentrée de septembre
il ya des rendez-vous qui vont
s'enchaîner des rendez-vous qui vont
s'enchaîner par rapport à de nouvelles
compositions également des projets
d'associations qui se met en place et
elle serait qu'un jour entre les campus
l'a8 pour moi vont cesser c'est parfait
pour lui à l'heure actuelle mais voilà
ils restent sont à 8 par rapport à des
programmes des choses qu'il met en place
encore mais il prendra la tête d'une
chaîne et qui sera le groupe c'est pas
le moment de se fâcher juste bras sur
moi s'est passé star